the amazon workers votes now being
tallied will decide whether organized
labor can make a comeback in the heart
of the anti-union south the vote
counting that began on monday marks a
second battle between a corporate
behemoth and pro-union activists in
bessemer alabama employees rejected
joining the retail wholesale and
department store union last year but the
national labor relations board ruled
that amazon unfairly influenced the
outcome and called for a do-over
election that's in part because the
company set up a mailbox that looked
like a voting booth giving some workers
the impression amazon itself was running
the election we've turned a lot of no's
into yeses once they got the information
that was more impactful
to their lives so yeah they're on board
as well
the union's leader says the company's
tactics have continued
they are conducting a ferocious
anti-union campaign
union busting bringing in outside union
busters hundreds of them
in a statement amazon spokesperson kelly
nantel said we look forward to having
our employees voices heard our focus
remains on working directly with our
team to continue making amazon a great
place to work
the move in alabama follows a recent
vote still being counted at two amazon
sites on new york staten island where
workers projected their critiques of the
company under its iconic logo unions on
the decline for decades have seen a
resurgence in the past year
signing up workers at starbucks stores
in buffalo new york seattle and mesa
arizona google fiber contractors in
missouri and a new york city rei
sporting goods store
workers seem empowered by the great
resignation the wave of workers leaving
their jobs during the pandemic
the company has been calling workers in
for mandatory meetings to explain to
them why they should not unionize the
company's perspective is that it works
better with employees when it does so
directly and not through a third party
but many pro-union workers say when that
happens it's the company that sets the
rules
one alabama worker was confident enough
to take aim at amazon's billionaire
owner who also owns the blue origin
space company it's not really worth it
to stay with the company who
doesn't care about me as much as they
care about jeff bezos going to the moon
it could take weeks to count up to 6 100
ballots before it's clear if workers
here have opted to unionize and whether
organized labor can gain ground deep in
the heart of dixie john hendren al
jazeera bessemer alabama